Yes!
- Hi!
So it's like that?
- Yes!
- [Josh] Am I sitting here?
- Yes, you are sitting there.
Oh my goodness, you just
seem like such a cool person.
- Really?
- Yes, and the more layers
I peel back about you,
you just seem like such a
good, cool, fun rad person.
- That's great, really?
You're very sweet.
Just don't peel back any more layers.
You're good right
where you are.
- Okay, I'll stop.
But listen, okay, first
of all, we were talking
in the news really quickly
about Jennifer Coolidge.
I'll just get straight to the point.
I think she was staring
at Lenny's everything.
- [Josh] He's a very
handsome man, I mean...
- [Drew] Is he free?
He seems like he would
just walk around naked
without an issue.
- I was mostly concerned about
what Lenny was gonna be like
because to me, he's such a rockstar.
And Lenny is-
- [Drew] literally.
- Truly, I mean, he's
an incredibly nice dude.
- Is it true, Jennifer
Lopez, Jennifer Coolidge,
Lenny Kravitz, they stayed
in a house together?
- No, no, this is the way it went.
Okay, it was Cheech, Jennifer,
Desmond, Callie, Darcy,
Sonya Braga, the whole cast.
They put me in a house and
they put Jen in her own house.
So I didn't get to hang out.
They had like a dorm situation going on,
like a beautiful dorm,
like the most beautiful
dorm you've ever seen.
- And you went there?
- Wine dinners every night.
- And Lenny was playing?
- Lenny would come down
and play music.
Yeah, and I had to sit at home by myself.
(audience laughing)
but I think they were
probably smart to leave me in
because I would've just had too much fun.
- They were like, "You two
need your beauty sleep."
- Yeah, it was truly one
of the most gratifying experiences
I've ever had on a movie.
Everything about it was one
of my best experiences, yeah.
- And I think that's paying off
because everybody's
talking about the movie.
There are 23 romcoms being made this year.
- Really?
It's about time.
- Right?
- Maybe we can do one, one time?
- Oh!
(audience cheer and applaud)
I wouldn't mind that at all.
Okay, I wanna be on one of your
vacations with your buddies.
You sent in a video.
I'm so in love with this
vacation or this moment.
Is it true there's ice and a sauna?
That's my setup.
What do you guys do?
- Well, it's not really a vacation.
I have a cabin.
I spend half my time out in the woods,
deep in the woods of Minnesota.
- [Drew] Another reason I love you.
- Truly, it's my happy place.
And one of the things we do in the winter
is snowmobile, and ice
fish and ice plunge.
So what's happened over
the last couple of years
is people around the lake know about it.
It's become this tradition
to bring in the new year.
People jump in that ice hole.
And I have a wood burning
sauna right next to it.
So you get in there first,
then you get in the ice, then
you get back in the sauna.
- It just sounds like so much fun.
- It really is.
- Okay, speaking of a
beautiful way to put things,
will you tell me about
the proposal that you did?
Again, where does it end with you?
- I mean, I wish I could say
that I'm usually this romantic,
but this was one of my best.
- Okay.
- Yeah, I'm really proud of this one.
So one morning, I was sitting there
and I was like, "Okay,
tonight's the tonight.
"I think I gotta do it tonight.
"I gotta do it tonight."
And I thought, "Okay, we're gonna do."
There's a beautiful little sandbar
at Little Palm Island is where we stayed.
And I had this idea to do this like,
what if I put like a message
in a bottle that rolled up?
And I went up to the concierge,
asked if they had an old wine bottle.
They did, took some
stationery from the hotel,
burned the edges.
I had it all timed out with the concierge
so that we're gonna be
out at 5:15 for dinner.
I need you to go put it at 5:14,
have the bottle in there
so when we can walk out,
it's just rolling up to the thing.
And that's when she found the bottle,
and that's when I asked her to marry me.
(audience applauding)
And it worked!
- All right, so let's add this layer in.
You make a mean lasagna apparently.
(audience cheering and applauding)
- I make two things.
I make really good ribs and
I make really good lasagna.
And lasagna was literally out
of necessity from college.
- I was gonna say you
learned to do it in college.
- It's not a fancy recipe at all,
but it's so good.
- But will you teach it to us?
- I will gladly teach it.
(upbeat music)